del lado derecho tenemos la estructura
del betacaroteno que es una molécula de
color anaranjado y es la que le da el
color a las zanahorias del lado
izquierdo tenemos el espectro de
absorción del betacaroteno y el
betacaroteno tiene color porque absorbe
luz en la región visible del espectro
electromagnético la región visible
empieza en aproximadamente 400
nanómetros
entonces si dibujo una línea aquí del
lado izquierdo tenemos la región
ultravioleta y del lado derecho
tenemos la región de luz visible aquí
podemos ver que el betacaroteno absorbe
luz en un rango de longitud de onda de
aproximadamente 450 a 500 nanómetros
pero para explicar por qué el caroteno
es anaranjado necesitamos analizar un
poco más la región de luz visible en el
espectro electromagnético
y aquí tenemos los diferentes colores
que hay en la región de luz visible son
los colores del arco iris
aproximadamente a los 400 nanómetros
estamos hablando de luz violeta pero
antes de la luz violeta tenemos la
región ultravioleta uvb y la región de
luz visible llega hasta aproximadamente
los 700 nanómetros o quizá un poco más
ahora aquí estamos hablando de luz roja
pero después de la luz roja está la
región infrarroja del espectro
electromagnético entonces aquí tenemos 6
colores rojo anaranjado amarillo verde
azul y violeta cuando isaac newton hizo
el famoso experimento con un prisma
escribió siete colores incluyó el color
índigo porque quería tener siete colores
en la región visible por eso
generalmente nos memorizamos rabay como
los colores del arcoíris pero yo he
sacado el índigo porque así podemos ver
mejor
la rueda de colores isaac newton fue el
primero en representar una rueda de
colores y nosotros podemos hacerla
nuestra si movemos el color violeta
hacia acá y el color rojo hacia acá así
el violeta nos queda junto al rojo y nos
queda esta rueda de colores que es muy
útil porque nos ayuda a ver la relación
entre los colores complementarios por
ejemplo si queremos saber cuál es el
color complementario del rojo
simplemente cruzamos la rueda y
encontramos que el color complementario
es verde así por ejemplo el color
complementario del violeta si cruzamos
es el amarillo y finalmente el color
complementario del azul sería anaranjado
entonces esto es muy útil porque nos
ayuda a pensar en por qué las cosas son
de determinado color por ejemplo si
tenemos una hoja de color anaranjado y
queremos saber por qué la hoja es
anaranjada
bueno sabemos que la luz blanca consiste
en todas estas longitudes de onda
consiste en todos los colores del arco
iris pero vamos a simplificarlo más
suponiendo que la luz blanca consiste en
dos colores complementarios por ejemplo
podemos decir ok esta parte consiste en
las longitudes de onda azules y esta
parte de la rueda consiste en las
longitudes de onda anaranjadas entonces
podemos suponer que la luz blanca
consiste en longitudes de onda de color
azul y anaranjado así que cuando tenemos
una luz blanca aquí entra luz azul y luz
anaranjada recuerden esta es sólo una
forma muy simplificada de entender la
luz blanca que incide sobre un objeto
anaranjado entonces si el objeto absorbe
la longitud de onda que corresponde a la
zona de los azules va a reflejar la
longitud de onda anaranjada y al
reflejar la luz anaranjada
si nuestros ojos se encuentran aquí
nosotros percibimos que el objeto es
anaranjado porque estamos viendo la luz
que es reflejada por eso es que las
cosas tienen algún color ahora si
regresamos al beta-caroteno aquí podemos
ver que el betacaroteno absorbe luz en
un rango de 450 a 500 nanómetros y miren
ese rango corresponde a las longitudes
de onda de luz azul de 450 a 500 se
absorbe esta zona por lo tanto se
reflejan las longitudes de onda de la
zona anaranjada por eso nosotros
percibimos al beta-caroteno de color
anaranjado en el siguiente vídeo
hablaremos sobre como la estructura del
betacaroteno permite que la molécula
tenga color